with the continuation of the coronavirus
situation
it has become mandatory to wear masks
inside
in several places for example here in
quebec in all
interior spaces public interior spaces
we are
required to wear max and if you don't
you can get fined you can get arrested
and especially the place where you are
can get fined and that is of course a a
much better way to enforce something
by finding the restaurant or the the
store you know in which
you are not wearing a mask so i think
i've been really hesitating people have
been asking me to make a video on the
symbolism
of masks now for weeks and i have been
hesitating
just because everything is still kind of
developing and it's such a very broad
symbolism so you can see this video more
as some thoughts on the symbolism of of
the masks in this particular context
what it can mean in this particular
context and we'll try to understand it
together hopefully
in this particular video you can use the
comment section
to give me your ideas as well try to be
a little more attentive to the comment
section
so that we can further the the thinking
about this situation with masks
and we can see how we can push it
further and maybe i'll make another
video
if that is necessary
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so in order to understand the symbolism
of masks in this
context we really need to be careful not
to let our minds go too far
in symbolic thinking because we we need
to try to at least at first stay close
to what is happening
and try to see what is happening through
a symbolic lens
and this symbolic lens does not exclude
the explicit
reason why the mask is used this
explicit reason is of course part
of the symbolic reason but at the same
time we also cannot avoid that symbolism
through analogies and through narrative
you know
taking on different forms and let's say
growing in its
its uh emphasis so i've seen people who
have been
focusing only on the narrative aspect of
the symbolism
only seeing it in terms of a social
narrative a political narrative
a narrative of power between different
groups and there are other people who
want to limit the symbolism only to the
medical use and saying there's no
symbolism here it's just medical
even if it's medical it's still symbolic
because the patterns
across the different levels are the same
and they are of course the same in terms
of medical so we'll look at that
a little bit like i said in order to
start we need to look at
the very specific reason why we are
being told that we have to wear masks
and the reason why we're told we have to
wear a mask is one which is
coherent with the use of masks
especially this kind of mask which is
more like a
veil than a mask the way we think of it
when we think of a mask we usually think
of wearing
something which is manifesting something
else so let's say you wear a halloween
mask or you wear a mask
a carnival mask something which is uh
which is a representation of something
else you know on your face
this particular version of the mask is
mostly to hide your face
is mostly to separate you from others
and so in that sense
it is more related to the symbolism of
the veil
there is a relationship between the the
carnival mask and that type of mask
and the veil as well but let's we'll try
to stick closer because
this symbolism is so wide that it's it's
going to keep wanting to take us
on all different kind of paths
so the explicit reason why we're told
we're a mask is because we need to be
separated from each other because we are
because of the
because of covid because it is said that
you know we can infect each other
we put on math in order to separate us
from
other people so that we don't infect
them so that we're not infected and the
opinions on that will vary extremely
you know you read people who are saying
that it's effective they were telling us
it's not effective
just you know a few months ago and there
were studies saying they were not
effective and then now they're telling
us it's effective right now
uh and that there are other studies that
say it's effective
in the end in the end that's why we end
up going back to the narrative level
because the the scientific information
seems to be so varied
and seems to change all the time that
it's or seems to
you seem to be able to pick in the
scientific information that you need
uh in order to in order to be able to to
give the the narrative that you want but
we can see even the na the medical
reason we can see that it has a
narrative function and so
we can think about it this way we're
told that
we need to be separated from each other
in order to not
infect each other and one of the
problems that this has caused is of
course a breakdown of the
of all of society everything broke down
all
all economy all meeting all form of
exchange
uh broke down and you can't perpetuate
that breakdown forever
and so one of the ways and so the mask
ends up being a marker of protection
it's you separate yourself in order to
protect yourself from others to protect
yourself from the disease
and so whether or not it is 100
effective
it also acts as a token and it acts as a
ritualized token
to signify between people that i care
about you
and i care about your safety and i don't
want you to get sick
and so it's as important as a narrative
token
which signifies the importance we're
signifying to each other that we take
this
this virus seriously and that we don't
want each other to be infected
and of course in terms of understanding
that
token function of something it does have
an effect you know
it has an effect in a kind of as a as
these waves of a pool
can have an effect on whether or not we
are
and it can help us understand some
superstitions as well you know i've
talked about
how a lot of superstition isn't as silly
as you think it is
when you understand it as a token which
focuses your attention
and so if you do a token gesture
to focus your attention like let's say
you're
in danger and you knock on wood well
that attention to the situation the
recognition of danger the act which will
which will
uh recognize that you're in danger and
you need to be protected
is already a movement towards avoiding
the risk that you're facing it's already
a focused attention on the problem
you're facing
and which will which will help in terms
of a
on a greater scale it will help in terms
of how you're affected by the situation
so
just wearing wearing a mask is in part
you know of course they give you the
medical reason that it's there to
protect you from each other but it's a
token reason as well
which is it's to signify and to attend
to the fact that this virus is around
and the fact that we're not infecting
each other that seems to be
the function that it is playing and all
of this is related
to the idea of separation and protection
separation and protection are of course
the same thing when you separate
something
from from something else you are
isolating it to a certain extent and you
are of course protecting it
now we need to understand this can help
you really understand
the veil in terms of the religious veil
the veil that
is worn by women in certain traditions
for example women in church
women in islam and also the veil that is
there on the temple
in the or in churches in orthodox
churches there's a veil on the holy of
holies
which hides the holy of holies and it is
of course
a similar reason in terms of narrative
which is that it is there to
separate to designate as other and
also to protect
so it's there to protect the inside holy
place
from the uh you know the secular the
secular
pro profanation from the outside that is
the incapacity to recognize what is
precious
but it's also there to protect the
people
on the outside from the holiness of
the holy place that is to those people
who aren't ready for something holy
it it holy things can
let's say they can be damaging to you
but i shouldn't even say that right now
it's probably something because that
that's like i just opened a huge door
that would be
uh we'll need to talk about in another
video so hold on for that video but
let's keep talking about
these masks and these veils so there's
an
analogy between the use of the veil in
terms of religious use and the use of
the veil in terms of this medical use
both in terms of what it's doing that is
separating isolating
uh protecting um and also the notion of
attending
the narrative notion of if when you put
when you create something like a veil or
you have these gestures
the other gesture which is also a form
of attending is of course
the gesture of putting you know purell
on your hand or washing your hands
they have all these bottles of purell
you walk in you squirt on your hand you
rub it you make sure everybody sees that
you're rubbing your hands with purell
then you go in and part of that is
really a
a marker of attention and it's actually
very similar
to going into a church and putting holy
water
in a catholic church and taking holy
water putting holy water on your
forehead
you know or on your body because it's a
manner to attend it's saying
i have entered a holy place and now i am
attending
to the difference between the inside and
the outside
and that is of course what you're doing
when you're putting pirell on your hand
you're marking
to everybody and to yourself that you
now need to attend and be careful
in this space and so it's even more that
than it is
about actually disinfecting your hands
because you know everybody touches their
face everybody touches their mask
you know there's there's very if you
look at the way that
it's happening in stores you can tell
that it has more of a narrative function
than an actual medical you know
scientific function because
people aren't trained in doing this
anyways i don't want to get off i told
you that this video would probably start
to kind of
shift in in many directions now
in terms of a narrative function
this is going to be the tougher one this
is going to be the tougher one
because it's going to seem like a
stretch to some but if i try to show you
some of the analogies
hopefully and also the other things that
are happening in
coordination with the use of these masks
then hopefully it will
will help you to to see what i'm talking
about now one of the important symbols
of the veil
has to do with the symbolism of the
garments of skin it has to do with the
idea
of the covering and the limit on the
outside of an identity or on the outside
of space
and so the veil acts as a transition
between the inside and the outside it's
it's kind of like a door it acts as a
transition space
between two identities inside and
outside and so
because it acts as a transition the veil
is also a breakdown of identity
it is the place where identity breaks
down and so if you imagine it for
example
looking at the islamic the islamic nikab
for example can kind of help you
understand this which is that
in the vision the vision of the niqab is
the
a woman belongs to her family belongs to
her husband
and she needs to be protected from the
outside
um and so so we put a veil
on her face and there is a breakdown of
identity
when she's outside you don't have access
to her
because she's preciously kept for her
family
so there is so the veil acts as in
making anonymous it makes the person
anonymous to you
it makes that you can't own the person
owning in a very broad sense in the
sense of identifying
and being able to name something right
when you name something and you have
someone's identity
you have some power over them and so the
making anonymous is a is a way to
let's say hold off the outside and
create this buffer space between
identities now
when the woman who wears a nikab goes
home then she removes her nikab
and then she is known by her family and
in her family now she her identity is
fully accessible
and she's completely uh you know
she is she's in a mutual
relationship of identity with with those
that are in her family and so
you can understand how the veil acts as
this transition between and not
an anonymous identity and a fully
revealed
identity okay and so one of the things
in terms of narrative
one of the things the the mask is doing
is also
a form of breakdown of identity and
i know some people are going to struggle
with this one but if we look at the
other things that are happening
in society we can see that this is a
move
there's a narrative happening if you
look at
talk about how covid needs to be
uh let's say needs to be an opportunity
to restart right an opportunity to to
reset
the economy to reset the way we do
things to start over
there is a lot of talk about discovering
the new normal
and all of this talk is talking about
using kovid
as a reason to transition into something
else
and so the wearing of the veils the
wearing of the masks
is akin to the breaking down of the
statues those two things the fact that
they're happening at the same time
although they almost they can seem
narratively unrelated to people
they are analogical the reason why we
anonymize people
we break down their current identity is
the same reason why people are taking
down statues
and the purpose is to enter into
a new identity to enter into something
which will
a new established identity
an example of this that which is still
there in western culture although maybe
not as prominent as before
is of course the use of the wedding veil
and so a bride
will put a veil on her face during her
wedding
and that veil is a form of separating
herself from the outside world
and it is in fact a form of a
you know and people are going to hate
this because it's so patriarchal
but it is a form of her putting aside
her ancient
identity putting aside her her family uh
you know moving away from her father and
her mother and
her family her old story
and now entering into a new identity and
so
when the bride comes to her husband and
then at the crucial moment
the husband removes her veil he is the
first one to see her
he is and that that connection is a it's
supposed to become a bond like they're
they bond and they create a new identity
as the veil is removed and so the veil
ends up being a transition space
between her old family and her new
family which which will now create
with their new husband and this is
something which is which is happening
right now in terms of not just like i
said if it was just the mask
i wouldn't be saying this but the fact
that we have
the mask and we have the breaking down
of statues
we have the riots and the protests that
have been lasting forever in the u.s
the desire to break you know if you look
at what was happening in portland
the desire to burn down uh to defund the
police to defund
systems of authority to also break down
they were trying to burn down the court
the the federal court there
and so you can understand in terms of a
narrative the desire to break down the
current narrative
and replace it with a new narrative
this of course does not mean that
everybody who is wearing a mask and is
wearing it for that reason
you know most people are using the mask
for the medical reason that is being
said
but nonetheless within even the medical
the medical narrative that is being
proposed
all of this is kind of melding together
into a narrative
and what is this world that we're what
is this new normal what is this world
that we're moving to
that we are going that we need to
prepare ourselves for
there are many aspects to it but one of
them seems to be
identification one of them seems to be a
movement towards mass identification and
you know at first it was just i was just
seeing kind of conspiracy theorists talk
about this but now
i'm seeing mainstream media start to
hint at the fact that
this new normal that we're going to move
towards is going to be
a it's going to be a move from this
ancient world of possible
anonymous existence towards a
full uh identification which will be
measured
in terms of biometric uh different
biometric measures whether it's going to
be
facial recognition or whatever method
they end up using whether it's going to
be a
a uh a kind of mark in the vaccine which
will make you
that you can be scanned you know and you
can be identified
and this will also make it possible
for you to travel or to participate in
different aspects of society
this is what we seem to we seem to be
moving towards we seem to be moving
towards
a a world of absolute identification
where everything
is accounted for and so it makes sense
that
we would have this moment of breakdown
because the breakdown
is also painful it's supposed to be
painful
wearing a veil wearing a mask is
unpleasant for
everybody and it's unpleasant even if
when you think of of for example
the notion of the of the islamic the
muslim woman
wearing a nikab it's also supposed to be
unpleasant for her why
because they want the person to when she
gets home
where her identity is supposed to be
strong and she removes the niqab
she has this sense of like freedom she
has this sense of here
i can be myself here i can i can exist
freely and so it's the same thing you
know
one of the reasons that i think it seems
that we are kind of
forced to wear masks that that these
separation even as the death count goes
down even as the
the the cases go down in
canada at least where i am the cases are
going down the death rate is going down
dramatically there's almost nobody
there's nobody dying anymore
we still will continue to have this use
of mass
and this use of separation so that we
aspire
for the new world so that when the new
world of
identification of absolute
identification is brought to us
we will be grateful for it we'll be
we'll be thankful that finally
we are free to now embrace this new
identity which is being presented to us
and so
that is my those are my few thoughts on
the mask and what is happening right now
now of course there are many many
aspects which i'm missing because
the the mask and veils is one of the
primal symbols it's one of the most
polyvalent symbols and is one of the
most difficult to
comprehend because the covering is
itself
everything technology is a covering and
so
all the symbolism of civilization it can
be reduced to this notion of covering
and so it's difficult to talk about it
because it engages
all of human action and human making and
human
human sciences of covering in terms of
technology and knowledge and everything
and so i try to limit my
understanding as close to what is
happening right now hopefully it was
helpful to you
but go go go nuts in the comment section
and i'll be really happy to try to
engage and maybe if there's some good
stuff in there
we can make another video on the subject
so once again thank you for your
attention and i will talk to you very
soon
as you know everything i am doing on the
symbolic world is
thanks to your support as i delve into
these difficult subjects and i kind of
move forward
in this direction it is obvious and you
probably understand that youtube will
not like me
and my videos will not be uh will not be
trending
and so please share this if you find it
useful
do all the things that youtubers ask you
subscribe and do all that stuff
and also if you feel like what i'm doing
is important go
check out the symbolicworld.com support
for ways that you can
support my work supporters get a free
patron
supporter only video every month and at
different tiers the
possibility of asking questions in
advance for the q a and also to have
monthly meetings with me
and in small groups to discuss symbolism
so you can also
go check out some of the designs that
i'm making which talk about the symbolic
world i currently made
an image of everything which tries to
encompass all of the cosmic vision
that i see proposed in the christian
tradition
within one single image and so once
again everybody thank you for support